the Joe Rogan experience but we're not
ruled by people let's really get into it
now okay let's get into it who were
ruled by artificial intelligence already
a hot-shit has been it's been an
experiment for almost 700 years
700 yeah more did you see today Joe it
was the biggest news I've ever seen in
my life that and I didn't get a chance
to vet it you know so I really okay I'm
not gonna say it but I did better
ourselves on the show okay I thought you
know a lot of these Christians out there
I mean they're really connected in with
the whole Q thing have you noticed that
Q and like you and ons are you saying
yes you know what is the Q people what
does that mean 17:17 within the letter Q
uh-huh and that means eight and then you
reduce that down to two and reduce it to
one you know it's a mystical thing oh so
it's like like numerology types
everything's numbers right and
everything is like appreciating the
numbers and that's why I told you
there's this whole process didn't you
smoke in a cigar you don't just go like
this you got it you have to sense it
smell it mmm
hold it I believe I'll have a light now
Joker thank you dang I love cigars no
one's gonna get mad at me for giving you
a cigar are they no no you're okay with
that yeah because you're on inhale okay
yeah no I can't I just can't do
cigarettes mmm but I'm gonna start on
cigars cuz they last a hell a lot longer
than a cigarette and they never go out
you smoke about half a one per day when
did you stop with the cigarettes cuz
last time you were here you were
chain-smoking I smoked three three packs
you were smoking three packs a day and
this was right after all the bull [ __ ]
went down and yeah I needed a smoke
screen between myself in the world
that's what my psychic counselor said
you're a psychic well it's my daughter
but she's a psychic counselor I'm sorry
Norris and say so they say [ __ ] like
that the youth Oh see there are another
wave like a smoke screen or glasses like
glasses kind of feel like that to me
sometimes like if I sunglasses on I feel
like I can like maneuver through crowds
better of course you can because you're
protecting your eyeballs because
everything is ghosts through your eyes
like those things those worms that they
got now they go right for your eyes you
know what I'm talking about right
Oh Jamie does schooled you are in this
show let's go back to the 700 year eh I
think first I don't want to lose that
we've been ruled by artificial
intelligence for 700 years
no probably longer it's just like
Babylonia no it's Babylon it's all
babylon babylon chant down Babylon you
know it's Babylon well yeah that's like
Iraq right sir mayor Mesopotamia that
very part of the world well that it's
not really part of the world so much as
it's part of the brain and the memory
now where was better that's changed now
was it it's over there somewhere in the
Bible as they say right it's in the
Bible I don't exactly know what part of
the world it's the Middle East Iraq okay
yeah and Iran what a crazy part of the
world you know I mean what an amazing
history that part of the world has still
it's happening yeah still is having as
per my tweet which was mischaracterized
by people of low intellect is what I'm
saying now and soon fucking-a to get
[ __ ] I don't say that anymore
now I say those of lower intellect isn't
you know what I think big part is about
Iran and the people's fight in Iran of
which I so I'm so thrilled and
supportive for the people the working
people of Iran who want to overthrow
their ruling class mullahs who you know
control the way they think do and say in
every aspect particularly for women and
that's getting ready to go and I hope
Trump helps push that a little bit
further too because everybody wants
freedom now hot from Hong Kong to Tehran
the Hong Kong riots are insane there but
like I can't believe what's going on the
strength of the human spirit it blows me
away well they've been riding for so
long now yeah I mean it's not slowing
down at all 17 weeks of Ryan
that is crazy hmm 17 mm-hmm everything
everything so find out sooner it's just
in the air so is 11 did you ever notice
that about 11:00 every time you look at
your clock it's something me 11 right I
don't know it just is I don't know what
it means just look at my watch and it's
always like more times than not
something 11 what does it mean to you
though just hey there's a okay just like
there's a pattern to this I don't know
it's just there again right there it is
it's like something synchronicities
synchronicity synchronicity is now put
it in the dictionary Urban Dictionary
trademark that that's the beautiful
thing about urban dictionary right you
can just like guy my new words right and
I love making up words me too I never
have though I don't think I made one up
but I like it when other people do I've
[ __ ] words up before but I never stuck
with them synchronicities yeah that's
legit thank you thank you so much thank
you that means a lot to me so 700 years
of us being controlled well I mean the
babylon thing the whole descent of
babylon which is artifice elf is
artificial intelligence that's right and
the Tower of Babel which is the terror
of artificial intelligence where where
everybody was trying to go higher higher
in the pyramid and the irr key where
there's only like a certain percentage
of people at the top and billions at the
bottom and chains you know not that
pyramid
I mean it's getting over its tip now
it's over it's not going to work anymore
because people got too damn smart and
god damn we I shouldn't say god damn you
just say it oh my god damn god damn
smart and I'm so proud of them because
like keep going keep going don't let
nothing stop you this is the first time
in the human history and and this guy
told me this once I have talked to the
most interesting people have ever lived
this guy he was the one that wired all
of Mexico for Ted Turner some [ __ ] some
old big old
pardis I used to go to before I stayed
too long but first they're fun but
anyways anyways um I forgot what I was
saying oh yeah he said we'd put these
satellites this is the age of miracles
two messages bouncing off satellites and
appearing in billions of places at once
that this faster than the speed of light
and that this this would engender a new
what do they call it renaissance in art
and everything that you know when art
gets [ __ ] cool
everything gets cool buildings commerce
everything gets creative and it's just a
creative creative time is coming from
after this particular time of like a
deadening or something or we didn't
think but now they can't hold it down
this is the first time in history I said
to him it seems to me like this might be
the first time in history where no
church or state can keep the facts from
the people as you said yeah that's true
that does feel like this and I mean
that's gonna create the most cool [ __ ]
yeah like cars that will fly or
something I don't know what how it will
manifest but it's high thinking and it's
good and the more we see the rock at the
bottom which is everywhere now you just
kind of keep looking up just keep
looking up don't look down right you
know when you're on that tightrope
that's what they say never look down
when you're walking a tightrope you just
keep looking forward and up a little bit
forward and up hmm you know and just
keep going it's tough for people right
now
[Applause]